carrying on from the uh what I consider
the
hesi program that I'm trying to organize
for those of you who want to follow me
and uh take note of what I'm saying to
do I've talked a lot about the weapons
and um you you your job is to try and
get the weapons the Joe and the Ken to
feel the same in your hands try to
remove the
mind getting in the way and say yes but
I know it's a Joe when I'm thinking
about doing Ken work with a Joe and and
I know it's the Ken when I'm supposed to
be doing some Joe work you can
um I shouldn't use the word play with it
but but sometimes you have to you know
make up your own items perhaps movements
just to see how um your mind mind falls
apart when you're trying to conjure up
some movement you think oh well that
doesn't work but at least you're you're
trying you know you're going to these uh
exceptional movements uh that you're
mind is creating but I'd rather you
stick to the format of the films that I
talked about because that is all
about uh a lot of IID develop through
the
mind and these films are going to come
out a lot quicker than you'll be able
to feel the benefit but perhaps uh
they're on YouTube so perhaps over
time you can go back to them recheck
them I you know remind you of what to do
this this film is going to be about
doing the tetsu side of it so what I'm
recommending the same as all the others
uh that you do repetitions of five
movements now when it comes to Tai Jitsu
we we go outside um what the weapons are
because the weapons you hold the K
always uh in the same hand you know the
right hand is always forward because in
Japan um centuries
ago everybody had to be right-handed or
they tie the left hand behind the the
person back so they couldn't use the the
left hand so there was wasn't any
left-handed
people in the martial arts side of it in
the samai side to my knowledge anyhow
you may want to prove me
different um
so what I suggest is if you've followed
the rest and you're starting to get an
idea of how to make things flow as part
of your body so there in extension of
your body the Ken and Joe and it's all
about becoming smoother with your foot
movement the haer gear is can you flow
are you still stumbling can you not
quite make the 360 degree with the the
hasso with the
Joe um that's very demanding do you
wobble a bit do you lose your balance on
some
movements so excuse me so this one's
about Tai
Jitsu it's best done if you can for your
personal training with a um regular
person that you're used
to the last thing you want to do is try
and do the same thing on different
people at first until you've sort of
started
tasting what it feels like to to be in
unism so that you can start thinking
okay I've never got
three movements feeling the
same on the same using the same
person if you're a teacher uh then I
encourage you to teach a
class tell the students to pair up and
and you know help them
find um this U this
balance the foot movement is very
important in the weapons but they should
start to become very important in Tai
Jitsu you know the way you open your
foot uh on a shagi the way you um sweep
the the back foot on a cat of G um how
you make steps and not too high off the
ground steps but more like sweeping
steps floating across the to Tammy as
close as you can you know rather than
big big step
and
and I remember Terry
Dobson he was a well-known
aikidoka I think he was the first person
to go
to American aoko that went to Japan and
oeni and he said iido is a bit like
dancing and and at first I was upset by
that statement but
uh I remember make an early film saying
that but now I can completely understand
what he means you once you're in control
of your body the beauty of movement does
become very much like the beauty of
dancing so um I just going to give you
two techniques for now they're they're
easy techniques and they're enjoyable
techniques and they're done from the
first one will be Shan
and it will be done from I handy those
that don't know what iamy means it means
the same so if I put my right arm out to
be have my right wrist grabbed by my
partner I means they will put their
right hand out and grab it's a bit like
a a cross ways but their right hand will
grab my uh right wrist so I means the
same
so from IAM to do
shagi um you'll do it in five uh
repetitions and first stick to one side
and then do iham with the left uh five
times if you feel that you're you need
your partner to have a go as well then
that's a good idea because you you will
gather information into your head about
how they feel
but because it's you training as Uchi
Dashi um you're it's not like normal
training you'll be a little bit selfish
and you'll be uh taking information in
about how you got on while you were
doing shagi while they're doing it I
normally wouldn't say this but this is a
an nesi program not a um give all you
can to your partner program
this is very much for your
self-development so in high Hami you do
emot shagi what means a positive
direction where you cross their body and
uh anybody that doesn't know this please
uh look up films or books and to see
what the iham Shi from a right hand or
left
hand wrist grab
is so they will grab you and you will do
th five
repetitions and your trying your aim is
over a period of time to get three out
of the five that feel smooth and exactly
the same in every section of the
movement this is this is your goal time
for may take years uh
months I don't think it'll take days
unless you're very high rank already and
then perhaps you're doing this for fun
or just to go back to basics
really this is all about building up
smooth
movement and uh moving
Mass so when you use the weapons and I
said earlier about dropping your
shoulders learning to
relax as you step across them try
pushing with your scent with your Hara
your stomach if if you like and and try
your stomach and going down towards the
pit of your
stomach
um two two in 2 in or
five what about 7 cm 5 cm below your
Naval and and and so your hand will be
turned in the shagi but feel that you're
when your you know your hand should be
in front of your Center in front of your
abdomen and try connecting by pressing
this this part of your body don't hold
tension in this just put your mind
there
now the next one I'd like to ask you do
is they do shanci towards your head and
you do Kash
so uh you're you're trying to
blend and the back foot as it sweeps
feel as it's floating across the the
tatami so iamot same thing repetition
five on the same side right first or
left first doesn't matter what you
choose and you're trying to get a
repetition of three of those out of the
five that feel exactly the
same if you're feeling you know stages
of it then don't get annoyed with
yourself just think that your timing is
out out and this means the weapons that
you've been training you haven't done
enough of the weapons because the
weapons are an aid to tajitsu CTO Sensei
said and I've said in many films before
he used to say when doing weapons think
of Tai Jitsu when doing Tai Jitsu think
of
weapons an easy statement to make but
very difficult one to
perform again five on the right five on
the left but between the five on the
right and before you go on to the five
on the left I suggest you let your
partner do five it gives you time to
absorb and reflect if you like with the
weapons if you go straight into doing
the left after the right you your body
can't amass this
information and
uh and it I remember when playing golf
they used to say try to forget the hole
you just had or else it will disturb
that next hole that you're going on to
and and I found this quite right you've
got to clear yourself so as with the
other film you can close your
eyes in breath through the nose out
breath through the
mouth try to calm yourself clear
yourself if it hangs into the mind and
it and it eats away at you then you need
to do a lot more work on a meditative
scale rather than you know iido is about
you being in control of you and this
process of becoming a better
Desi Uchi or soo dasi soo means outside
student so really even though I'm saying
this is a program for you as an Nashi
really is a program for you as a sadashi
you're not in a full-time Dojo you're
not living and staying
there okay so I hope this
helps and again if anything's not clear
please get in touch with me and we'll
try to explain it a little bit better if
the Tai Jitsu is haunting you then you
must learn to clear the mind and do the
next
five um with a clear mind as if it's the
first time you're doing them to try not
to bring baggage from the F from the
previous one the biggest problem with
the human being is want but I want to
achieve it I want to do it I want to get
it
right in time as the years go by you'll
find that want is your enemy rather than
cleanly doing the techniques as I'm
trying to give you
them the aim is to get three rep
repetitions the same I personally have
never had five repetitions the same if
you achieve this then you're better than
I am and Well Done o Sensei used to get
it wrong as well s of Sensei said many
times he so sense he make mistakes we're
human beings but we love our art and we
can make it a lot better than it is now
thank you for doing this program with me